>> Rachel: YEAH.
I'M DEFINITELY PULLING MY WEIGHT
ON THAT PART.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IS NOT
THE ONLY ELECTION IN VIRGINIA
TOMORROW AS THE FIGHT FOR THE
NEXT STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WRAPS UP.
JASON IS THE SON OF A CUBAN
EXILE AND LOOKING TO BECOME
VIRGINIA'S FIRST EVER LATINO
ELECTED AS A.G.
VIRGINIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
CANDIDATE JASON JOINS ME NOW.
JASON, WELCOME TO PRIME TIME.
SO YOUR PLATFORM IS, YOU KNOW,
SPEAKS FOR ALL RACES.
I WILL SAY THAT THE LATINO RACE,
YOU HAPPEN TO BE LATINO
YOURSELF.
THE LATINO POPULATION ALMOST
10%.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A VERY CRITICAL
VOTE.
TELL ME HOW VOTE GO L. GO AND
REACTION TO YOUR FANTASY?
>> EXACTLY RIGHT NOT ONLY THE
FIRST LATINO EVER ELECTED THE
FIRST CHILD OF IMGRANT EVER
ELECTED AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I SAY TO EVERY GROUP WHERE IT'S
KOREAN AMERICANS OR LATINOS IF
YOUR FAMILY CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
SEEKING HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY
THERE,'S A GOOD CHANCE YOUR
FAMILY IS A LOT LIKE MY FAMILY.
BE THE BIGGEST HONOR OF MY LIFE
TO BE YOUR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY WANT
THE SAME THING.
THEY ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE SEEING WITH POLITICIANS
PLAYING POLITICAL GAMES WITH THE
SAFETY OF OUR SCHOOLS.
SO CONCERNED PAROLE BOARD
VIRGINIA LETTING OUT COP KILLERS
MURDERSERS AND RAPISTS BACK ON
THE STREETS EARLY AND SOME OF
THEM COMMITTED MORE CRIME.
SEEING INFLATION THROUGH THE
ROOF.
SO MANY AS YOU KNOW, RACHEL SO
MANY ARE ENTREPRENEURS.
THEY SEE HOW HARD IT IS TO START
A BUSINESS.
WE ARE 49TH IN THE COUNTRY IN
STARTING A BUSINESS RIGHT NOW IN
VIRGINIA.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE FLOCKING
WITH US.
IN OUR POLLING WINNING THE
LATINO VOTE AND SO IS GLENN
YOUNGKIN.
WE HAVE REALLY LOVED EVERYBODY
AND SO OUR CAMPAIGN.
IT'S NOT ABOUT LEFT ARE ORIGHT
IN VIRGINIA.
IT'S ABOUT A MOVEMENT AND COMMON
SENSE.
WINNING INDEPENDENTS BY DOUBLE
DIGITS 12, 15 POINTS RIGHT NOW
AND READY TO WIN.
>> Rachel: DEMOCRATS THINK WE
OWN HISPANICS.
RACISM, TRUMP, INSURRECTION THAT
THEN THEY WILL -- FAN ALSO RUN
OUT AND VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS.
I KNOW A LOT OF LATINOS.
I ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE IN
VIRGINIA HE HAD ARE HISPANIC.
THEY CARE ABOUT CRIME.
THEY KIND OF MISS THE TRUMP
ECONOMY.
>> WELL, I MEAN, LISTEN, AT THE
END OF THE DAY, YOU HAVE AS I
SAID THIS IS A COMMON SENSE.
THEY ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE SEEING WITH THE
CURRICULUM IN OUR SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
MURDER RATE IN VIRGINIA IS THE
HIGHEST IT'S BEEN IN TWO
DECADES.
THAT'S EXACTLY THE POINT.
YOU HAVE ONE PARTY RULE IN
RICHMOND IT'S BEEN FAR, FAR TO
THE LEFT.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND INTUITIVELY WE
NEED A CHECK AND BALANCE IN
RICHMOND.
THE MESS YOU ARE SEEING IN D.C.
IT'S BEEN HAPPENING IN RICHMOND
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
I LIKE TO SAY COMMON SENSE
HASN'T BEEN VERY COMMON IN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
I MEAN, THEY'RE TRYING TO REDUCE
FROM A FELONY TO MISDEMEANOR.
ASSAULTING A POLICE OFFICER.
GETTING RID OF ALL MANDATORY
MINIMUMS FOR DRUG DEALERS.
THEY PASSED THAT BILL THAT ENDED
MANDATORY REPORTING REQUIREMENT
FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT IN SCHOOLS.
VIRGINIANS SUPPORTING VIRGINIANS
TO GET CHANGE AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
JASON FOR A.G..COM THAT WANT
CHANGE.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND RIGHT NOW THE
STAKES IN VIRGINIA AND THAT'S
WHY THE WAY WE ARE FRAMING THIS
RACE YOU WANT A POLITICIAN
THAT'S MY OPPONENT.
YOU WANT A PROSECUTOR, I'M YOUR
CAN CANDIDATE.